all the pressure we put on these kids to
figure out stuff at 22.20 and like 30
years old you should have your life
figured out I don't know a 40 year old
that has their life figured out but Gary
my friend's already married what the
[__] does your friend
it's marital status have to do with your
life stop looking at other people these
pressures we put on ourselves for no
reason starting with your age we're
living to a hundred like think about if
that's true think about where you are in
your journey you're only 30 in you're
only 40 in you're only 50 in like it's
just a lot of pressure for no reason
we're looking at the wrong things
we're valuing the wrong things this
practice of gratitude and a lot of
different Frameworks really matters and
I think it would take a lot of pressure
off of people